hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about how to learn languages on
your own
[Music]
and remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe you can click on the
bell for notifications
and by all means join me at link where i
learn languages so it doesn't really
matter whether you're at a school or
entirely on your own to my mind
to be a successful language learner you
have to be independent it is you and the
language so
it i think the first part of learning
languages on your own is to have that
independent mindset i'm going to learn
this language
and so that it's my responsibility all
the things that happen during my journey
to fluency are going to be you know
dependent on me the learner that i think
that's that's the first thing that's
very important to be independent
so this is going to affect the language
learning material that you search for
the grammar rules that you look for
explanations about whatever you do is
going to be dependent on you the learner
and remember i've mentioned this before
the sort of three keys to language
learning that i once heard from a
professor at san diego university in the
states language learning success depends
on three things
your attitude the time you spend with
the language and your ability to notice
now the ability to notice will develop
on its own if you have the right
attitude and if you spend enough time so
enough of the theory and i should say
too that the importance of being
independent and responsible for your own
actions
doesn't just apply
to learning languages it applies to so
many things in life you have to take
charge whatever happens to you
are things that may be beyond your
control what is
within your control is how you react to
these things
and so with language learning you know
it can be lonely it can be a bit
frustrating therefore anything that
makes it easier
uh obviously is a good thing so i i want
to digress a little bit by mentioning
you know how link helps me be an
independent language learner one feature
is the playlist or in my own case i tend
to go to you know listen to the course
audio so that i always have the audio of
whatever course i'm on with me i can be
listening in the car on sort of
bluetooth through my car radio i can be
listening on my airpods while i'm
working out while i'm doing the dishes
so it makes me
sort of my own language learning you
know language lab with me all the time i
think that's important okay you may want
to sort of say well now how do i get
started i know nothing i know don't know
the language i know nothing
well
because you're going to be an
independent language learner you have to
make investments so you are going to
invest in books at least i do so you
know i have not ever tried learning
dutch we have dutch at link one day i
think i will tackle dutch and so i saw
this book
essential dutch grammar it's in the uh
dover i believe series and these are
excellent grammar books because they're
very small very thin no exercises no
drills which i avoid like the plague i
just want
a brief overview initially of the
language which i can flip through
and then i need this as a reference from
time to time i go back to it so that's
one investment you can also invest in
starter books which also will give you a
bit of an overview of the language
and
some sort of a bit of content
second thing about language learning is
the need to find content all the time
major activity is looking for content
when i was a language student in hong
kong i spent a lot of time in the
bookstores and in behind me here lots of
books
chinese books chinese with glossaries
after every chapter but i was constantly
looking for new material even though i
had material already i would buy stuff
that i think i'm going to need in the
future because you can never get enough
you know content
in terms of starter books it to me it
almost doesn't matter which starter book
you use you can use several starter
books
one common theme as an independent
language learner is it's good to cover
the same material in different books
it's good to cover
you know
sort of grazing interleaving
it's good to you know do
typically these starter books have you
at the restaurant and the post office
and stuff like that do it in different
books and this is again it's true for
studying anything if you're doing
history you're better off to read three
different books about the same period in
history
in order to finally have the
sort of
get an understanding and remember some
of the key events and so forth if you've
covered them
from different perspectives the same is
true in language learning now i have a
preference now for our many stories
but i do believe that they're typical of
the kind of story that is a great way to
get started as an independent learner
but if you're learning polish you could
use
pyotr's material at realpolis.pl
if you're learning english aj hogue is a
wonderful source of these kinds of
stories or content with
you know different points of view
circling questions lots of repetition
you're listening to it over and over
again it becomes almost hypnotic you're
listening to it and slowly this material
is washing over your brain and getting
the brain used to the language you're
not worried about writing exams you're
not worried about doing drills answering
questions you're just letting the
language come in
listening and reading every so often if
you're curious about the point of
grammar you can look it up you can
google the conjugation of a particular
verb
if you're unlinked you can when you look
up the the word in the dictionary we
also have a conjugating dictionary so
you can look at the conjugation and then
forget it don't try to
ace anything or master anything or
remember anything just keep letting the
language wash over you so as an
independent learner that's sort of the
initial period now if you if you're in a
a classroom environment
the learning still is done by you as an
independent learner and what you do
outside the classroom
is at least as important as what you do
inside the classroom because inside the
classroom the teacher decides what
you're going to study the teacher
decides what they're going to teach you
you may not be interested in what
they're teaching you ready for that
particular point of grammar as an
independent learner after the classroom
you go home and you're curious about a
certain tense or a certain you know
declension you can look it up so you
the attitude of an independent learner
doesn't necessarily mean that you aren't
in a formal class it just means that you
are
determined you have made the decision
that you are going to learn this
language
uh so so the initial period i i
definitely recommend
repetitive listening to relatively
simple stories with high frequency
vocabulary
now the next stage and i've said this
many times
is to find material that is now
interesting authentic but not too
difficult
there is a shortage of that kind of
material but it does exist and so here
again you've got to look on the internet
search for the material you can get on
our forums at link and see what other
people have recommended very often
anything that's of a conversational
nature podcasts
these kinds of things are going to be
easier than
more formal material like a book or
something and even when you move towards
authentic material like books i have
found
because i'm interested in history
non-fiction for example history is
easier than literature i'm more familiar
with the subject matter the vocabulary
used is sort of more relevant to things
that are of interest to me
than
more literary language
but as an independent learner you have
to move from the sort of relatively easy
call it sheltered protected material
with lots of repetition
uh you have to move from that to
uh you know genuinely authentic material
where you are going to be driven more
by your interest in the subject matter
than
uh
the sort of effort to learn the language
after a while
you're not saying i want to learn the
language i want to learn the language
which is how you're motivated at the
beginning but rather i'm interested in
what they're talking about and therefore
i am learning the language because i am
pursuing my interests
now learning a language can be a lonely
activity
it can be all-consuming
uh if you are spending an hour a day
it's not too bad if you're spending two
or three or four hours a day you get
consumed in this thing and it starts to
take a space in your brain which can
lead sometimes to a sense of frustration
and so you sometimes you have to take a
break from it
it also helps in my view to have some
sort of very specific goals like here
again at link we have you know uh
goals in terms of number of of links
created in other words number of words
you have saved number of words you have
learned number of words you have read
so that
as you're in this fog of trying to you
know come to grips with this language
and sometimes feeling as if you're not
making progress
if you can see that actually i have read
so many words i have you know learned so
many words these very concrete
goals or milestones can be motivating
and help keep you moving when you're in
the doldrums and make no mistake that
there will be periods as an independent
language learner where you're doubting
yourself doubting your ability feeling a
sense of frustration and you just have
to persevere you have to keep going
through that and that's where
obviously your original commitment
as well as your interest in the subject
matter so it doesn't matter if i'm
improving because i'm enjoying what i'm
doing
but also some of these specific you know
concrete goals
uh
can help you
okay i'm kind of i'm fighting the
language right now but at least i i
saved a hundred words or i
i read so many words or these kinds of
things that can kind of confirm to you
that you actually are moving because
make no mistake as long as you continue
to spend time with the language
listening reading speaking
writing
and uh if you remain motivated and even
if the motivation flags a little bit
the more time you spend with the
language the better you are getting the
brain is absorbing all of this
uh stimulus
and forming patterns out of it and
sometimes you have the impression that
you're not making any progress and all
of a sudden surprisingly you know three
months later certain things come
together for you so
to that extent i think being in a
classroom can be motivating because
you're with other people you have a
teacher hopefully stimulating you you
have other people that you meet it's a
social it's a get-together opportunity
uh learning entirely on your own for
some people can be a bit of a lonely
experience although i think it's it's
the more efficient way to learn is to do
it on your own listening reading writing
and then getting online you know if
you're not in the classroom i mean
eventually you have to speak but you can
find people online there's italki and or
a link we have tutors so you can get on
and talk to people
because every so often you know you
can't just be listening and reading
totally in your own little cocoon
you you want to connect to people you
want to see what you can say
get some reaction from other people and
so therefore i think it is important to
connect with people online
in my own case
two or three times a week would be a lot
uh and and
then i get of course the
reports from my tutor which i analyze
and slowly i i improve my accuracy in
the language so
you know within the limits of this uh
video here i just wanted to touch on on
what i consider to be some of the
highlights of learning a language on
your own
uh i have done other videos on a similar
subject and i would offer these to you
as further uh discussion of the same
subject i don't remember quite what i
said there maybe i repeat myself but one
is called become an independent
learner
and the second one is called learn
languages for your own reasons so i
invite you to go and look at those two
as well thank you for listening bye for
now
[Music]